taliban fighters overlooking land that
would soon be theirs the armed group
tried to take ghazni three years ago but
failed this time it had control in a
matter of hours
you can see our fighters with tanks in
the city we're doing an operation
heading towards the police headquarters
there was a prison break and the
prisoners were released the taliban are
here and we're moving forward to capture
more places keep watching us
is accused of doing a deal with the
taliban for safe passage to escape to
kabul
these taliban yell the governor has run
away
flaunting trucks and equipment claimed
in recent conquests the taliban was seen
escorting the governor through its new
territories
afghan police arrested him shortly after
for surrendering without a fight
ghazni is the 10th provincial capital to
fall in seven days prior to this week
the last time the taliban had held a
provincial capital was five years ago
and that was only for a matter of days
its location is also significant as the
gateway to the south
of the provincial capitals that have
fallen ghazni is the closest to kabul
just 150 kilometers away the taliban now
hold about two-thirds of the country
including much of northern afghanistan
provinces in the west and rural areas in
the south all now leveraged they're
taking into negotiations with the afghan
government they've got what they wanted
from the doha process they've got a u.s
troop withdrawal which means a nato
troop withdrawal
and i can't see why they would
at this stage
compromise they think they can take
afghanistan by force
and that's what they're going to try and
do over the next few months here in the
capital concern is growing about the
possibility of a taliban takeover
we worry a lot when we see the taliban
capturing the provinces it's natural for
us to worry about it
we are asking the taliban not to destroy
cities they should do a peace agreement
they should agree to a government they
can be in power and we can be in power
together
the government is bringing some special
forces back to kabul to bolster security
it means risking the loss of more
provinces to the taliban
so all lies tonight on the second and
third biggest cities of afghanistan
herat if it is proven to be true that
the taliban do have full control of that
city now also in kandahar and i should
add all flights are cancelled in and out
of kandahar symbolic i guess of the the
amount of fighting in and around that
city to see whether or not the
government can hold off the taliban in
that city tonight and then also in the
province of helmand in lashkar-ga the
provincial capital there heavy fighting
the taliban making more claims about
games in that city also so the
government looking at a three-pronged
situation as they head into the evening
charla bellis live for us in kabul let's
get reaction from the united states now
defense officials reported to be
increasingly concerned by the taliban's
advances she have returned to his life
for us in washington so she have the the
biden administration has been sticking
to this line that this will draw
will happen um as scheduled but they've
got to be worried about what they're
seeing in afghanistan not just the the
taliban advance but the speed of it
that's what seems to have taken everyone
by surprise
in washington we've had these several
intelligence estimates over the last few
days as to when kabul will be cut off
from the rest of the country and
potentially will fall those estimates
ranging from weeks to to months that
clearly is the main
the main concern now we understand
deliberations are underway about whether
to evacuate the u.s
embassy in kabul there are about four
thousand personnel in that embassy of
which about a thousand five hundred are
americans another travel advisory was
issued by the state department asking
all americans to leave afghanistan
clearly what they're thinking is if
if there is a need to have a mass
evacuation of u.s citizens from
afghanistan then at least it will just
be the people from the embassy and not
no one else in in in afghanistan in case
in case various parts of the country are
simply inaccessible it's interesting we
were just looking at those talks in doha
there's a new york times report that
among the
items on the agenda
for zalman calizar the the us envoy
there was trying to get the taliban to
make a commitment not to attack the u.s
embassy in kabul should they take should
they take kabul so that's rather
interesting but in the meantime joe
biden he's been asked repeatedly now
whether he's having second thoughts and
the answer is constantly no he says this
is time now for the afghans to take the
fight to the taliban to fight for
themselves he says that a trillion
dollars has been spent in afghanistan
there are 300 000
u.s trained afghan military personnel
now with state-of-the-art equipment of
course most of these figures are
complete nonsense do we now know because
of the
the the leak of the afghan papers of the
washington post a couple of years ago
which basically said the us military the
u.s administration after the u.s
administration bush obama uh have
basically lied about progress in
afghanistan for years but that's his
that's his line and for now at least
there is overwhelming popular support
for a withdrawal from afghanistan but i
think where the biden administration is
getting more and more worried is about
the optics about being seen to have
mishandled the withdrawal we keep on
hearing comparisons potential
comparisons to the last chopper from the
u.s embassy in saigon in 75 which
clearly had a huge impact on the u.s
psyche the u.s sense of exceptionalism
although here we are another failed u.s
war and so this that's what the biden
administration really wants to wants to
avoid and there is a sense that even
though donald trump and his supporters
and the republicans
do support a u.s withdrawal they're
starting to sense that there it might be
scope here to to criticize the way that
biden has handled this donald trump in
the last few hours issuing a statement
saying look i negotiated the withdrawal
but i would have said it would have been
conditions based this is all going
terribly wrong
she habertonsi life was there from
washington thank you